the dancer and choreographer and she
calls herself an action architect
Elizabeth Streb is phenomenal what she
does is push the limits of what human
bodies can do her story really
illustrates for me what I call
cultivating a passionate obstinacy she
is determined to figure out not how to
defy gravity but how to push the
boundaries and dance with gravity so
what she does with her dancers is she'll
have them fall from a platform that's 20
feet in the air straight down onto a
series of mats one of her most powerful
works is incredibly short her dancers
dive through a pane of glass that's it
there's a pane of glass hanging from the
ceiling and they dive right through it
and as she says it shatters little
pieces of it may fly into the audience
the dancer make a cut but it is this
incredible experience she is so
passionate about the work that she does
and so single-minded she says our job is
to create an experience that people may
not be quite comfortable with but that
moved them in a way and our other job is
not to die in front of them so she
understands her limits but because of
her determination and this this
passionate obstinacy to not give in to
gravity she has created extraordinary
works of art that kind of tenacity is
essential for creating anything new
because a lot of times people will say
you're crazy that's not going to work
and you need the determination to just
say okay I hear you but I'm gonna try it
anyway
you